youssef souidi aujourd'hui on se trouve
de nouveau sur ce 3 lundi puisque la
dernière on n'avait pas fait grand chose
finalement ou plutôt on peut mieux faire
allez prendre à ça et c'est parti j'ai
regardé s'il est des nouveautés par
rapport à la dernière fois il y en a eu
quelques unes bas il ya surtout des
nouveaux animaux sur les îles des
nouveaux trucs échoué bas par exemple la
voilà un morceau d'avis le reste
essentiellement des bugs ont été fixés
puisque c'est vrai qu'il est pas mal de
bugs c'est quoi ça là-bas à ces syndics
peut-être qu'il ya un bateau échoué
on va commencer par couper du bois
aujourd'hui on construit une petite
cabane avec un lit on va commencer par
te faire la petite hache qu'on adore
temps et les crabes ya pas je vois aucun
car depuis thaler jaloux je suis très
que très peu rassurés on met tout dans
un tas tac et on va couper du bois la
partie un peu ennuyante en place au plus
tard pourquoi d'avril comme ça et c'est
qu'il ya un requin c'est ça attendez
est-ce que c'est pas lui là bas est ce
que on n'est pas en train de le repérer
le conte un nom c'est un caillou il ya
une sardine en plomb peut l'attraper à
mains nues ja poignard monga farmer bon
ce truc là bam inspire toi il faut y
aller on va même bateau en ramant c'est
beau hein
allez on prend life [ __ ] et on y va on
fait une bouée avec leurs ados [ __ ]
tac
alors si ça alors là c'est bien bateau
le truc est cool c'est quand les bateaux
on trouve des morceaux de moteurs en
gros qui permettent de fabriquer ensuite
un bateau motorisé et ça ça va beaucoup
nous c'est une ré sénart essonne où
l'animal ou lui fait peur le court on va
lâcher un stick en pleine mer dieu ou
l'abandonner
je te jure on va te faire la peau
goulasch mr goodfish qu'est ce tu vas
faire à l est pas très méchant sroka et
web où je compte père en fils on manie
la hache notre pénis ah [ __ ] c'est
technique ils veulent qu'on se fatigue
et combien noyer le combat on est bien
dans la merde j'ai construit un marteau
pour rien qu'est ce qui se passe
l'excèdent brut à hodiall et les
attractions là sur un toboggan
j'ai vraiment envie de buter en plus à
une fois de la viande mais qu on s'en va
avec une aurait alors l'arrivée ça cuit
alors à quoi elle sert si elle cuit pas
s'il te plaît
j'ai relancé nouvelle partie de ce qui
est pas mal de bugs voilà un crabe donc
déjà lu on kidnappe direct alors dans
cette fameuse boîte cette fois qu'est ce
qu'on a doctype c'est une blague a opté
des bandages c'est sa voix ça dégage
mais sur ce seront des députés tout ce
qui se mange pas wihr demont à bretelles
voilà il faut c'est qu'il a de roche
pour faire le truc pour chasser j'ai mis
dix minutes à cause de ça comme ça que
j'écris de ma colère c'est parti on va
les chasser le requin pour aller
explorer l'épave là bas là bas là bas
là-bas au lab rat voyez viens te bats
grosse tempête
olala bon finalement à s'attaquer à plus
petit aujourd'hui la sardine voilà allez
enfin c'est comme le requin en tout
petit peu plus gros mais c'est aussi
féroce attention on saute sur le requin
on lui courent après et on fait et sa
mère diane jardine voilà et là hop 4,61
à lui bon match j'te pick up l'acheteur
pick up lavialle 1 mais viennent à mais
il a autant de courage que manger de
muscles quoi se régaler revient aux
plats ils sont bâtis la brède sur cooper
est un gars qui tape le regardez moi ça
mouille à saissac on est doué c'est ça
qu'on est doué on s'envole avec un trou
ou plonger ça dépend mais non mais pas
il mais on se fait défoncer par un
palmier quoi regarder mais au moins on
peut voler je suis aladin mais je n'ai
pas un tapis volant bien trop voleurs
bon gars le soleil se lève j'ai
travaillé durement toute la nuit même si
pour vous ça doit être une seconde j'ai
fabriqué au lait voilà je sais que vous
êtes déçu moi même je me dis mais c'est
tout c'est tout people cas mais
attention ce n'est pas tout voilà j'ai
quand même aussi fait un toit est ce que
je propose c'est d'aller défonce à un
requin j'adorerais faire le bateau
motorisé alors live on va juste aller
chercher leurs actes comme on l'appelle
ça je vais le coupé comme ça non pas lui
foutent le feu le couple a dit plus
grosse bio et quand il pleut on se met
sous le toit
c'est cool hein c'est de la merde à
tomber qu'on voit rien au hockey en fait
on est bloqués sur l'île quoi super au
monde veut partir il ya une trompette up
et voilà on vient faire une porte cgt
mais vraiment du coup on chez nous à un
problème c'est qu'il n'y a pas de mur
mais bon ça c'est un petit truc
auxonnais voilà vous savez bien et là je
pense qu'on dorme voilà on peut que
dormir la nuit
c'est génial mais mon lit est trop grand
pour chez moi je me suis prêt à regarder
d'écouter ou alors faut laisser tout le
temps la porte ouverte et le faire
dépasser au gt durement temps de travail
est soudainement
on va faire une découverte incroyable
dans cette épave d excuse aux une tortue
une leona doucet les rhodiens ont fait
qu à leonardo sur leur peuple au cul des
sketches dont le casier skoda en place
un problème voilà c'est ça c'est ça
qu'il nous faut on cherche la tortue on
est bien monsieur o o et moi bien
regardez là on a pris à partie mais
manque encore trois ou quatre parties
pour faire le moteur
alors qu'est ce qu'on a essayé un casier
avec le carburant est en pleine forme et
après ça on va devoir changer dit les
enfants on va devoir trouver les pièces
manquantes ont fait le bateau motorisé
on va partir à l'aventuré changer deal
changer d âge à l'oublier le truc
principal [ __ ] allez on y va en mer
non non le temps s'il te plaît non je
vois plus les autres il quand leur butin
requins la fin le but un truc qui pour
un steak mais gigantesque j'allais pas
le toucher la cooptation nasa vient de
mon gars c'est celle au graal c'est le
graal oh mon dieu un poisson-clown on se
rabat sur ce poisson au plat il est
quand même beaucoup plus gros qu'une
sardine hareng pas se mentir
oh mon dieu c'est la dernière chance
j'ai besoin de ton steak s'il te plaît
allez juste un petit coup dans la gueule
et je te laisse tranquille bien là un
nom tellement de choses qu'on fait en
arrivant sur une île un film bien sûr
ont déchiqueté un requin mais
détermination
le courage
l'envié la motivation
aucun jeu rabais sur l'île je te fais
des petits soir nous sommes les
meilleurs amis du monde
tu vois merde je n'ai pas de faire de
mal au final je mets juste adoptée
arrêtez moi aussi je t'aime tu sais
grimp ont valu ans encore d'amour albert
je fais tellement à l'intention ordure
tu veux que l'agent son ovale agences en
nombre en veux tu en fais pas regarde je
te fais sauter auraient voté près c'est
parti la nuit tombe mon petit albert il
faut se mettre en sécurité on va faire
un petit feu voilà mon rôle à attention
t'approche pas trop se risquer à une
cuillère un albert s'est endormi si ce
n'est pas mignon e le jour se lève
alberta viande ovine en grandvaux oui
j'ai une petite surprise pour tous
aujourd'hui
regarde ce qui nous attend un lit tu as
vu ça le maire va sur le lit albert va
je sais bien qu'à pas l'habitude des
lits mais c'est pour ton bien si plus
confortable pour faire sur deux regarde
albert là t'es pas bien alors albert la
nuit est et baume ou pas dis moi tout
jeter cotinière ça fait du bien même
réussi à faire ce que je voulais faire
depuis 2h [ __ ] gshc osa plus les canes
spvm et la vidéo cannabis
je crois qu'on a fait autour de stands
est de diplômes à mais pourquoi ne pas
refaire et vidéo dessus aux prochaines
mises à jour qu'il y aura pas mal de
contenu qui sera ajoutée mais ma boîte
vocale vidéo ça vous avez vu ont surtout
retenu dans une nouvelle vidéo merci de
me regarder de chaumont bis
[Musique]